also nicht haltbar dass wir als fünf
millionen euro bekommen jetzt bei kik
als hilfe pro monat und wir alleine 13
50 euro mietkosten haben das treibt mich
um mich treibt und sich über 200
millionen kapital bisher die schließung
gekostet haben wir sind aus über
wirkenden grund geschlossen
ich glaube man aus übergeordneten
gründen geschlossen das hat man ein
recht auf entschädigung
in österreich wo wir sind verhältnis zum
umsatz österreich machen real anzahl das
verhältnis zu deutschland der hilfen
eins zu zwölf wir kriegen also die
zwölffache in österreich es ist nicht
richtig länder wie österreich und malta
werden bei den hilfen gleich behandelt
wie deutschland wissen alles in europa
wären vielleicht jetzt ruft wie daimler
oder bmw aber dass wir völlig vergessen
werden bei ihnen helfen nicht ehrlich
ich finde es unglaublich dass in
betracht aber hoffnung
also wir sind aus anderen gründen
geschlossen man aus besonderen gründen
geschlossen ist ein recht auf
entschädigung
kik hat bisher überhaupt kein geld
bekommen vom staat
das muss man einfach festhalten 19.000
mitarbeiter ist ja nicht keine
entschädigung dafür bekommen
kurzarbeitergeld ist eine versicherungs
geschichte also ich würde das muss man
schon klar wenn ich auch trennen und
auch darstellen